[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avec mes parents un jour on s'est amusé
à compter le nombre de déménagements
37-37 déménagement 37 changement de
maison
alors vous savez tous à peu près ce que
c'est qu'un déménagement vous en avez au
moins fait un c'est stressant on perd
beaucoup de choses beaucoup d'objets
alors 37
je me suis arrêté de m'attacher aux
choses aux objets aux maisons mais à l
inverse
j'ai commencé à m'attacher beaucoup aux
gens parce que finalement pendant ces
déménagements j'avais j'avais réalisé
que ce qui diminuait c'était le nombre
d'objets mais par contre
s'additionnaient les êtres vivants
autour de moi chaque nouvelle maison
étaient des nouvelles rencontres
par exemple à nevers où j'ai habité
peut-être deux fois et je n'ai
absolument aucun souvenir
mais je me souviens très bien de la
personne qui tenait la mercerie de la
rue des monts tapez 1 on a passé
beaucoup de temps à discuter je
l'écoutais alors moi je fais comme ça un
genre de jeu relie les gens je me relie
aux gens je me crée mes propres racines
un intranet perso un petit peu ça me
donne je pense une stabilité personnelle
qui peut être avec les déménagements
n'était peut-être pas très clair alors
ça ça m'a sam a créé mes racines et un
peu plus tard dans mon travail j'ai
commencé à construire sur ses racines et
à élever mes statuts mes sculptures
debout comme nous en équilibre comme
nous avec nos doutes nos difficultés
mais avec de belles fondation et moi
quelque part mais fondation c'est vous
alors ce ce lien un peu avec les gens
près et loin de moi certainement
développer une empathie un peu excessive
mais à l inverse
ça m'a aussi donné une profonde
intolérance pour les conflits pour tout
ce qui nous divise tout ce qui nous
sépare qui nous détruit
alors c'est devenu l'objet de mon
travail dans mon atelier
j'ai étudié les conflits et ce qui
m'intéressait c'était de de comprendre
dans les conflits et le moment où les
choses basculent comment ça se passe
entre des êtres entre des des peuples à
quel moment les choses passent de votre
côté et dans cette étude mon but c'était
de trouver des outils des armes pour
nous tenir debout parce que à un moment
on tombe tout ça parce qu'ils font rien
qui tombe peut-être pas mais fascinant
on tombait tout le tout le challenge
tout ce qui nous donne la force et
comment on se relève
quels sont les outils qui vont nous
aider à rester debout ou à aider la
personne à côté qui est tombé à se
relever alors j'ai travaillé sur
beaucoup de ces thèmes
donc j'ai créé des sculptures sur tous
ces thèmes là et en particulier sur ces
outils il y en a un qui me tient
beaucoup à coeur et qui nous a été très
utile
il n'y a pas très longtemps c'est le
courage et c'est pour ça que j'ai
travaillé sur sur le courage qui a
quelques temps nous a préservés de de la
barbarie et j'ai créé une sculpture
je vous présente les braves
ils sont sur la plage du débarquement
omaha beach pour ceux qui connaissent
peut-être à saint laurent sur mer et je
les ai voulu debout planté mais dans les
conditions pour rappeler voilà le ce
qu'était
le temps au moment du débarquement alors
c'est un c'est un défi il y avait
beaucoup de problèmes techniques
évidemment beaucoup de contraintes
sérieuse pour pouvoir mettre cette
sculpture sur la plage et la liste a été
d impossible vous savez celle qu'on vous
donne tout le temps à chaque fois vous
voulez faire quelque chose on vous dit
mais non mais ça tu peux pas alors j'en
ai entendu beaucoup j'ai entendu enfin
tu n'y peux tu ne penses pas un
il ya de l'eau sur la plage ah ben oui
et ça c'est sûr et puis non mais mais
mais comment tu commences à te tiens ben
je sais pas je vais les poser et puis il
n'y a pas de vent avec un peu de chance
alors non il faut effectivement faire
les toutes les rencontres qu'il faut
pour que les choses fonctionnent et et
puis il y avait on m'a beaucoup prévenus
sur les autorisations parce que
effectivement pour mettre 20 tonnes sur
une plage sur le littoral français et 50
tonnes dessous surtout sur une plage
aussi mythiques comme à bitche c'était
un peu effectivement compliquée et moi
là la seule autorisation qui
m'intéressait c'était celle des vétérans
parce que vraiment il y est elle donc je
leur ai posé la question très simplement
en commençant ce projet je dis est ce
que pour vous ça vous choque parce que
ce n'était pas mon but ou est-ce que
vous êtes sensible à cette démarche sur
le courage et ils ont été enthousiastes
dont qui l'ont suivi dans cette belle
aventure et ça ça a été la force pour
moi de continuer parce que bon voilà
pour le reste c'était des problèmes avec
des solutions
puis après j'ai comme vous vu beaucoup
de catastrophes continuer à s'accélérer
et à nous envoyer des images incroyables
sur la planète on a tous vu les tours
tomber on a on a tous vu fukushima et
que c'était à la liste est très longue
vous la connaissez comme moi mais elle a
fait grandir évidemment et on a tous
ressenti cette peur un set chose diffuse
qui commence à étreindre un peu tout le
monde aux quatre coins de la planète qui
nous qui nous met à l'écart les uns des
autres mais en même temps
il n'y avait pas il n'y avait pas que ça
moi j'ai regardé aussi autre chose c'est
la fraternité
il ya eu pendant tous ces moments
terribles une fraternité extraordinaire
moi ça m'a émerveillé de voir comment on
est tous descendus on a tous été
portoricain récemment on a tous été
charlie on est on avec peut-être courage
aussi on est tous été on est tous allé
dans la rue
ensemble on s'est tenu la main face à
l'adversité et ça c'était quand même
assez extraordinaire
alors moi je me suis dit mais ici on
était capable de se réunir comme ça tous
ensemble mais pas autour de la mort
autour de la vie si on pouvait tous se
réunir se connecter pour créer pour
innover pour construire et pour faire
des choses qui ont l'apparence comme ça
impossible mais qui nous donne
énormément d'espoir alors ça c'est toute
l'âme du projet vitesse dont je vais
vous parler voilà moi je je me suis dit
que il fallait créer une sculpture c'est
devenu mon un peu comme une intuition un
peu comme une urgence créer cette une
oeuvre qui nous rassemblerait tous un
peu comme au premier jour de l'humanité
est gelée symboliser avec 1 millions
d'empreintes de mains de nous tous aux
quatre coins de la planète et vous
souvenez voilà les premiers des premiers
humains sur cette planète ont eu envie
de laisser leurs traces sur les grottes
de lascaux
voilà deux alors à l'asco moderne dix
ans une oeuvre on serait tous
participants et qui iraient s'installer
et avec laquelle nous resterions tous
connectés
alors j'ai cherché longtemps un lieu
parce que comme pour les braves il
fallait trouver un lieu qui qui soit
universelle puisque c'était l'idée c'est
qu'on soit tous ensemble dans cette
culture qu'on fasse beau voyage ensemble
alors il fallait trouver un lieu et il
fallait un lieu universel qui parce
qu'ils parlent à tout le monde donc aux
quatre coins du monde à toutes les
toutes les religions toutes les cultures
toutes les générations
ça c'était déjà pas facile mais je me
disais qu'il fallait aussi trouver un
lieu qui parle à nos émotions parce que
pour faire un peu ce contrepoint se
battre contre toutes ces peurs qu'on
veut nous infliger qu'on veut nous nous
nous ancrer et il fallait quelque chose
qui soit assez magique pour qu'on ait
envie d'y aller qu'on ait envie de ceux
de participer tous ensemble j'ai
finalement rencontré ce lieu et je joue
je vous laisse le découvrir
[Musique]
pour
m
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous voyez rêver grand alors voilà ça
c'est le rêve que moi je suis en train
de réaliser et j'avais un finalement
c'est je vais vous le résumé installé
sur la lune une sculpture vivante
puisqu'elle s'appelle vita elle parle de
nous elle parle de vie qui serait un
cocon fermés le jour et la nuit
s'ouvrirait pour laisser l'humanité se
déployer et toutes ses empreintes de
mains nous parler et il faut et on reste
connectés avec cette sculpture comme un
petit point lumineux de temps en temps
pour ne rien déranger mais qu'on
pourrait faire pulser pour rester
connecté avec elle alors en général
quand je fais une sculpture et que je
suis au pommeau voilà à ce point là je
vais sur place et oui et j'ai je vais
voir un peu les humeurs ce qui peut
avoir une incidence sur la sculpture
pour la finir là c'était un peu
compliqué et mais pas impossible
toujours donc finalement dans mon
atelier
j'ai accueilli des gens extraordinaires
qui sont venus me raconter la lune pour
que je la comprennent j'avais quand même
mille questions et il ya eu une série de
gens très bienveillant astro physiciens
ingénieurs de l'espace alors le premier
ingénieur de l'espace qui est venue
alors qu'ils venaient dans mon atelier
donc vous voyez les braves un atelier
avec quand même moi je soude de travail
les métaux donc beaucoup de grosses
machineries et et là je lui raconte mon
projet et donc il me dit très très
chouette projet ni lors très bien mais
tu comprends
toi tu es en tonnes et nous on est en g
alors voilà il faut changer j'ai compris
qu'il fallait changer d'échelle
alors c'est passionnant parce que c'est
un autre monde qui s'ouvre tout d'un
coup il faut voilà c'est pas une
impossibilité
c'est un c'est une ouverture voilà
comment on va trouver les solutions et
on va apprendre plein de choses alors
j'ai appris que le jour sur la lune il
fait il fait 150 degrés et puis la nuit
- 120 on peut aller jusqu'à moins 120
donc ça fait des amplitudes un peu
énorme
et puis alors il ya des bonnes nouvelles
je n'ai pas besoin de fondations
ça c'est bien parce que sous les bravia
50 tonnes et des micropieux mais là je
pose vita et dont la pause elles restent
donc ça c'était vraiment une bonne chose
et alors on a beaucoup beaucoup
travaillé il ya eu une autre personne
très importante c'était jean audouze qui
m'a donné une autre phrase comme ça il
ya eu des moments clés dans tous les
projets comme ça il ya des moments
importants des paliers et jean audouze 8
me est un astrophysicien extraordinaire
très connue très compétent et qui est
donc pareil dans mon atelier je lui
racontais et à la fin il me dit mais
vous voulez la mettre où exactement sur
la lune la sculpture alors là c'est
merveilleux parce que moi j'entends
c'est donc possible parce que si la
seule question de ceux de ce directeur
de l'institut d'astrophysique à paris
c'est simplement de savoir où et que ça
c'était peut-être un petit souci mais
pas comment c'est que tout leur est bon
il y aura 1 il ya des grands moments de
solitude bien sûr dans tout ça on est on
il ya des paliers vous les connaissez
peut-être imposé dans les projets comme
ça un moment où tout s'arrête
voilà on n'avance pas et et puis il ya
des moments où les gens voient vers le
haut et puis vous revoilà faut sauter
trois marches et tout devient possible
c'est merveilleux il faut profiter de
ces moments parce que c'est l'énergie
qui fait que ces projets avancés
l'enthousiasmé il faut il faut le
partager il faut leur distribuer il faut
s'en servir pour monter ses c'est une
vraie un vrai vrai moteur alors des
ingénieurs j'ai travaillé avec eux
pendant plus de quatre ans et on a
trouvé des solutions à chaque chose
l'ouverture qui se fait uniquement de
façon organique sans mécanisme
simplement avec la chaleur du soleil et
et elle sera visible donc je suis allé
au cern qui a eu la main qui m'a fait
l'honneur de me convier pour lancer le
projet donc on l'a lancée là bas les
premières empreintes de
ont été lancés à genève dans ce
merveilleux un des plus prestigieux
laboratoires scientifiques au monde et
aujourd'hui est bien le voyage cette
odyssée artistiques et scientifiques de
plusieurs étapes donc on est parti dans
la stratosphère vita a été envoyé à plus
de 50 kilomètres d'altitude c'est ce
qu'on appelle des age of space le bord
de l'espace où on voit la courbure de la
terre
et voilà donc ça c'est pas de la 3d elle
est vraiment là bas il c'est une photo
qui a été prise d'en haut
et après ça il y avait une autre étape
très importante c'était de la tester en
microgravité donc je travaille avec eux
j'ai travaillé avec la nasa d'un anorak
c'est pour en vous pour tester la
sculpture dans la station internationale
station spatiale iss
et vous voyez le 19 février dernier
vous m'imaginez à cap canaveral invités
de nasa sp6 pour ceux qui connaissaient
le musk pour assister au lancement de
spe 6,17 ce que cette fusée qui
emportait avec elle la vita et au milieu
des expériences et elle a été testée là
haut avec succès par par thomas pesquet
voilà c'est lui qui tient la sculpture
dans la main et qu'il a réussi à
l'ouvrir et
[Musique]
alors c'est moi ce que je veux vous dire
c'est que ce qu'on dit impossible
c'est simplement souvent une difficulté
à laquelle il faut trouver une solution
et cette solution
on la trouve cette lumière elle vient
des étincelles qui qui s'allume quand
nous nous connectons quand quand nous
nous additionnons tous nos talents et
nos enthousiasmes
alors moi je pense que l'impossible est
un mot qui n'a qui n'a que le poids
qu'on veut bien lui donner
alors faites moi plaisir ne lui en
donnait aucun parce que comme ça vous
pourrez être assez léger pour faire le
voyage avec moins vers la lune
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]